muchas gracias por el espacio yo lo que
hay que tener claro es que cualquier
proceso de paz sea en colombia o en que
el país del mundo es sumamente complejo
yo creo que a pesar de las dificultades
que ha tenido el proceso colombiano con
él con el grupo de las farc
creo que los avances igual son notables
no es sino recordar dónde estaba
colombia hace 10 años y ver dónde está
colombia hoy y la verdad que la realidad
del país sigue siendo muy distinta en el
sentido favorable
bueno de cara al próximo gobierno usted
ve posibilidades de que se fortalezca la
implementación en qué condiciones está
por ejemplo hoy la jurisdicción de
especial para la paz
pues yo creo que no podemos perder de
vista que el acuerdo se firmó hace como
bien decías hace cinco años y desde
antes de eso en verdad el conflicto
colombiano había comenzado a cambiar con
esto quiero decir que la implementación
plena de los acuerdos no es la solución
mágica a todos los problemas de colombia
es importante que se implementen bien y
sobre todo con el tema de la gente
mencionabas para poder cerrar la página
del conflicto con las farc pero lo más
importante que tenía que hacer colombia
hoy es pensar en su futuro en seguir
perfeccionando su democracia en aspirar
a tener un sistema capitalista de libre
mercado que sea más incluyente que sea
amigable con el medio ambiente pero que
permita un desarrollo real de colombia
la única forma que vamos a alcanzar una
paz verdadera en colombia es viviendo en
una democracia desarrollada con
oportunidades para todos los acuerdos de
la habana si fueron un paso importante
para callar los fusiles de las farc
sobre todo pero son totalmente
insuficientes por sí solos para darle la
vuelta a colombia que necesitamos
bueno y en este gobierno el asesinato de
líderes sociales incluidos firmantes
aumentó a cifras récord porque no se les
está procediendo que cree usted que ha
fallado en esa implementación
en colombia el problema de los
homicidios siempre ha existido y yo no
no soy el santo de devoción del gobierno
actual tengo muchas diferencias con el
gobierno actual pero si no mira los
números históricos lo que es la muerte
de líderes sociales lo que es la muerte
inclusive desmovilizados y lo comparamos
con épocas pasadas creo que colombia
como país de nuevo viendo la película ha
mejorado
cualquier muerte eso sí quiero ser claro
cualquier asesinato de cualquier
colombiano sea un líder social un
desmovilizado cualquier otra persona es
algo que es totalmente
inaceptable y que debe ser tratada pero
lo único que esto muestra también es que
hay muchos temas por resolver yo no creo
que eso sea un asunto simplemente el
gobierno de turno creo que quien sea el
presidente en las próximas el próximo
periodo que por cierto tenemos
elecciones en mayo del año entrante va a
enfrentar problemas similares y tenemos
que seguir tratando los con la misma
convicción con la misma perseverancia
con que tratamos el tema de vencer a las
farc tanto en el terreno militar pero
también de lograr el proceso de paz que
logró su vez en definitiva